. I have warned everyone that we
are going to be seeing an explosion
of radicalization through right wing
media during these next two years.
I've been saying for months now that Trump's
insanity is going to be replaced by right wing
media insanity, and that will include Fox News
having to do something wacky to get an audience
back from Newsmax and on. But it will likely
also include Newsmax and 018 going even more
extreme now that Donald Trump is gone. And we
haven't had to wait even a minute to see it.
Newsmax host Chris Saucedo. I actually appeared
on this guy's old radio show some years ago.
Chris Saucedo claims that Democrats
are pushing us towards civil war.
Let's take a look and then discuss, in my opinion,
Democrats dangerous rhetoric. They're vacuous
charges and feigned fear are pushing America
toward a civil war. The question remains why?
Many on the Republican side have noted on many
occasions that Democrats have disarmed their
voters through irrational fears of firearms,
those same Republicans rationalize they would
be foolhardy for Democrats to pick a civil
war fight that they would assuredly lose.
But the Democrats wouldn't be alone. Now, can you
folks think of a nation on the planet Earth that
would benefit from belated by or pushing for
an American civil war? I can't. That's right.
Joe Biden's buddies, China.
If America is pushed into a civil war by
the Democrats, that will benefit the world's most
inhuman, racist slave state, China. The policy
course charted by socialist Democrats is counter
to American freedom, liberty and prosperity.
Their rhetoric may threaten our very existence,
the republic itself. Someone should wake up
Mitt Romney, Pat Toomey and Ben Sasse. I know. I
know. You might be saying. Wait a second. Hold on.
Wasn't it Trump and Don Jr. and Rudy Giuliani
and Marjorie Taylor Greene and Lauren Bobert,
who were pushing us closer to civil war by
fomenting and inciting an armed insurrection
to try to keep the guy who lost in power? Does
this guy, Chris Saucedo, not remember that it was
armed, violent Republicans that stormed
the Capitol weeks ago? But Chris Saucedo
says it's Democrats pushing us toward civil
war. Was it Republicans who for two months
hesitated to even admit that Joe Biden had won the
election, threatening the very basic institutions
of democracy? But it's Democrats that are pushing
us toward civil war and Democrats that are putting
our country at risk of not being a Democratic
country. The people who draped themselves in
the Confederate flag, which represents literally
the loser in the civil war, stormed the Capitol
to try to overturn the results of an election. And
they are now the ones saying Democrats are pushing
us to civil war. How can this be now? The one
funny thing there isn't there isn't much funny
about this, but there is one funny part. Newsmax
guy says Democrats are pushing us to civil war,
but they would lose because they don't
have weapons because they're against guns.
Newsmax guy seems to think that if there were
such a civil war, it would be Republican citizens
versus Democratic citizens, just like random
voters fighting with handguns and rifles in the
streets. The reality is that in such a civil war
that was started by these insurrectionist, most
Americans would be staying at home and it would
be the insurrectionists versus the full power
of the U.S. government and military. So the idea
that Biden and Democrats would lose is very funny,
but I don't even want to focus on that because
it is so unbelievably absurd. But the bottom
line here is that Democrats are not the ones
inciting a civil war, fomenting a civil war
or demanding a civil war. Newsmax, OCN and
others that are broadcasting and promoting
disunity and conspiracies while perpetuating the
election fraud lies are the ones pushing us closer
to civil war. I don't think it will happen for a
variety of different reasons, but if it were to,
it's not going to be Republican and Democratic
voters fighting it out with handguns. And as we've
talked about before, geographically, that also
doesn't make sense since increasingly, you know,
we talk about red and blue states, but really what
we have are urban areas and even suburban areas
which are heavily and leaning more to the left
in states that may be blue states or red states
with significantly more red rural counties around
them. So all of the language they're using about
civil war is wrong. All of the framing they're
using about civil war is wrong. But the idea
that it's Democrats fomenting it doesn't pass
the sniff test, as you've heard me say before